musik ist wie sex und etwas ziemlich
mysteriös schon ein bisschen musik kann
bei uns so viel auslösen
trauer angst freude und noch viele
andere emotionen
warum wir so auf musik reagieren und
warum musikgeschäfts werke ähnelt das
erfahrt ihr jetzt bei pixum science
fiction die video days präsentieren den
rollt klappt um das größte club event
der welt in der frankfurter
commerzbank-arena zigtausende feiern
hier drei tage lang avicii david guetta
steve aoki und viele viele andere
die creme de la creme der djs ist also
da und es wird eine eigene video des
area geben tickets habe ich am ende des
videos für euch aber warum werden die
menschen von musik so mitgerissen und so
emotionalisiert zunächst trägt musik
unser limbische system im gehirn an das
für unsere emotionen zuständig ist
es kommt aber noch ein effekt dazu der
ein bisschen der wahrnehmung von düften
erinnert wir menschen verbinden sehr oft
erlebnisse mit bestimmten gerüchen unser
gehirn speichert diese ab und sobald wir
ähnliche duftstoffe riechen kann es
diese erlebnisse wieder ins bewusstsein
rufen
ihr kennt das alles wenn ihr als kind
zum beispiel irgendwann mal in katzenkot
getreten seid dann prägt sich nicht
unbedingt das bild davon ein sondern
vielmehr der gestank sobald diese
gerüche erneut wahrgenommen werden sagt
das gehirn euch sehr wahrscheinlich
achtung aufpassen und parallel dazu
können ekelgefühle ausgelöst werden
beim hören von musik treten dagegen oft
gefühle wie trauer glück freude und so
weiter auf oft beruht diese emotionale
reaktion auch auf eine verknüpfung mit
einem ereignis viele liebespaare
verspüren beispielsweise bei ihrem
kennenlernen song starke emotionale
gefühle oder was wir alle kennen sind
die streicher aus psycho
wer verspürt bei dieser musik nicht in
blanken horror gespeichert werden diese
musikerlebnisse im schläfenlappen
hauptsächlich in der rechten hälfte des
gehirns
kommen wir zu den hormonen ein
konzertbesuch oder ein event wie der
world klappt dome besteht neben der
musik den menschen den musikern und der
location eigentlich hauptsächlich aus
hormonen also in euch während einem
konzert werden nämlich unzählige davon
ausgeschüttet und das geht vorher schon
los wer sich schon mal auf ein konzert
gefreut hat kennt das starke gefühl der
vorfreude ausgelöst wird es durch
dopamin angekommen und sobald der
künstler losgelegt hat wandelt sich die
vorfreude um in ein glücksgefühl
hier kommen die endorphine die
glückshormone zum tragen neben dopamin
und den endorphin spielt noch ein hormon
eine wichtige rolle
oxytocin es wird vor allem dann
ausgeschüttet wenn man sich sicher fühlt
da wo man ist und ist das bindungs
beziehungsweise liebeshormon genau diese
ganzen hormone werden auch beim sex
ausgeschüttet musik ist sozusagen sex
ohne geschlechtsverkehr hat aber im
körper eine ganz ähnliche wirkung
und musik hat noch eine unglaubliche
wirkung
ursache dafür ist die verarbeitung von
musik im gehirn wir lernen nämlich mit
musik ich sag mal 1000 mal besser musik
beansprucht unser gehirn in ganz
besonderem maße
wir müssen tonhöhen höheren melodien
erkennen wofür wir die zeitliche abfolge
der töne erfassen müssen und den takt in
den rhythmus den müssen wir auch
verstehen und gleichzeitig müssen wir
akkorde mit ihren harmonien und
disharmonien analysieren die ton färbung
also die instrumente und deren position
einsortieren
das gehirn hat mit kaum etwas so viel zu
tun die mit musik und das hat folgen
bei profi musikern sind die areale des
gehirns besonders stark ausgebildet die
die hände mit denen des hörens und
analysieren verbinden und das bedeutet
musik verändert unser gehirn das führt
dazu dass wir mit musik besser lernen
super learning das hat ja schon meinem
video über die besten lernmethoden
erwähnt man hört einfach musik während
man lernt der effekt ist ich habe am
eigenen leib erfahren
frappierend man lernt schneller und kann
den stoff besser behalten und alles was
man singt behält man auch besser das
macht sich der youtube-kanal dorf fuchs
zunutze er singt zum beispiel die
dynamischen formen und wer jetzt dann
auch noch mit sinkt der lernt die formel
nochmal besser musik ist unser täglicher
begleiter ob aus dem radio dem fernseher
oder aus dem smartphone
wir werden ständig mit musik beschallt
große feste werden mit bestimmten
musikstücken verbunden besondere
ereignisse mit musik gefeiert und jetzt
gibt es genau ein solches wahnsinniges
ereignis bei dem musik im mittelpunkt
steht die video days präsentieren den
world klappt um vom fünften bis siebten
juni 2015 findet in der commerzbank
arena in frankfurt eine riesen party
statt david guetta hardware steve aoki
avicii und viele viele viele andere und
auch und das ist sensationell bekannte
youtuber wie vincent li oder ag sind
dabei
tickets gibt es hier und zur geschichte
der tonaufzeichnung mit der die
umfassende verbreitung von musik begann
geht es hier unten auf dem kanal einfach
geschichte clavinova marty bringt
spannende fakten zur geschichte vom
platten tonbänder kassetten cds und
schließlich mp3 allerdings wie immer
natürlich auch in der video beschreibung
und meine frage an euch geht ihr auf
solche events wie den world klappt um
was er lebt ihr da ist es ein solch
emotionales erlebnis wie viele schildern
schreibt es in die kommentare und
ansonsten sehen wir uns auf dem gold
klappen bis dann bleibt dran